mein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einer case mary-kate challenge
weiß das ist ich auch nicht
[Musik]
wir haben jeder 15 namen auf kleine
papierschnipsel geschrieben das heißt
wir haben jetzt ein glas mit 30 namen
drin und wir werden nun abwechselnd drei
namen ziehen und dann löst darfst du mir
sagen ok von den drei personen will ich
die person küsten die person umbringen
und die person heiraten verstanden
möchte anfang juli 1 golden retriever
nummer zwei ist sarah also weil das
schwester und nummer drei die person
juli hat ist katja glaser wird das wird
interessant
also du hast golden retriever sarah und
katja welche person möchtest du
umbringen welche person mich zu küssen
wenn ich mich zu heiraten würde
[Musik]
ich bin und meine damen und herren das
heißt nur 10 euro zwei und nummer 3 als
wir schauen mal in das erste kleine
papierschnitzel ich hier rein was hier
steht heidi beutin ok kassel seit juli
ausgeschrieben
die baldwin stand auf zetteln nummer
eins auf zettelchen nummer zwei steht
elena fisher und auf dem dritten papier
das ist sehr interessant gerade auf den
dritten papier stehe ich warum gibst du
also hey die baldwin helene fischer und
mich selbst ich glaube ich würde mich
selbst heiraten ja was soll ich mache
mich selbst der küssen ich würde mich
selbst heiraten ich glaube dadurch kann
man nichts verkehrt machen und dann
würde ich helene fischer umbringen und
handy beutel küssen
durch ein super fischerhude zieht wieder
drei zettelchen hier und darf dann sehr
gut gezählten der woche
julia hat den namen felix jedem zac
efron und baby also juli welchen von
diesen drei personen in diesem jahr aus
verschiedenen sparten zac efron
schauspieler felix i em music nasa von
schauspieler baby
[Musik]
kirsten und bringen die welt
nein wir wollen natürlich hier niemanden
irgendwie zu schaden kommen aber das hat
die challenge freunde seine hand geht
wieder hier in das in das glas ding rein
also freunde wir haben hier bei mir
diesmal auf dem ersten zärtlichen
draufstehen dass ich das mal aufbringen
sollte haben wir hier als erstes ich
krieg mama von luca weil die mutter also
meine mutter steht auf dem ersten
zettelchen auf dem zweiten session steht
george clooney und auf dem dritten
zettelchen was ich hier gerade aus dem
glas gezogen habt steht justin bieber wo
ich mag alle folgen also ich würde sagen
das nicht george clooney töte weil ja
keine ahnung mit ihm kann ich am
wenigsten anfangen so ist die tür noch
offen
es regnet ja es wäre sinnvoll
endlich sieht hier mal schön aus im bild
jetzt wird es wieder nichts schön also
george clooney würde ich auf jeden fall
umbringen jetzt weiß ich halt nicht
heirate ich meine mutter das geht ja eh
nicht was ich mit papa feuerrate
deswegen will ich sagen ich kürze meine
mutter und ich heirate justin bieber das
war ganz gut oder
[Musik]
mich gezogen von spongebob schwammkopf
luca also nicht umhinkommen es was zu
machen
die wirklich man bessere doha hinter dem
ersten türchen verbirgt sich upgrade
meine damen und herren also ein youtube
dann haben wir hier den nächsten
zettelchen haben wir manuel neuer
vielleicht bin ich auch gar nicht
lukrativ und auf dem dritten zettel
steht geschrieben
steve jobs ich würde sagen dass ich ab
und töten würde weil ja und dann würde
ich denke ich steve jobs heiraten und
manuel neuer küssen weil das ist ein
foto wir sind voll viele männer nahmen
einfach voll wenig frauen die jobs
heirat des ich heiraten toten dann zu
mir wie alt das ist ja auch
aufgeschrieben auf dem zweiten zettel
steht letztes rennen okay da sind auf
dem dritten zettel von jule steht
geschrieben kann ja ach du scheiße das
sind nicht alles ich würde die heirat
katja sich kirsten im alter du wird
zweimal die wir im regen krasse
statement numero uno dos tres also wir
haben drei städte die meine damen und
herren auf dem ersten steht geschrieben
ich glaube da steht das steht julie
julia auf dem zweiten zettel steht heidi
klum also endlich mal habe ich ja auch
ein paar teams am start
hey komm ich habe die idee und auf dem
dritten zettel steht auch oft gleich den
namen geschrieben also julia heidi klum
und alexis wenn ich glaube ich würde
heiligtum küssen
alex ist ein heiraten und dich umbringen
wenn du mich umbringen oder dreckig mich
natürlich wäre ich mich rächen wenn ich
tot bin vielleicht mit einem rechen
kendall jenner waren 8 cdi t die comedy
ok krass kendall jenner thomas müller
und antoine wen würdest du küssen
hauptsache sie ja thomas müller
geschrieben
ich glaub ich hoffe dass eine richtig
lustige ehe wir haben die letzten 13
jetzt hier für mich meine damen und
herren das heißt ich schaue mal nach was
sich hinter dem ersten türchen verbirgt
nämlich ich denke mal eine dame hinterm
erstens hätte städte kylie jenner also
vorhin hatten wir die campbell die sind
geschwister kraftbrühe rallye dakar dem
ersten tag im zweiten habe ich justin
ich glaube das ist unser job nicht
justin bieber also keine jenna justin
und hinter dem dritten zettelchen
subjekt sich elia also mein guter freund
und manager
das ist richtig komisch ich würde gerne
töten
ja weil ich nicht schaffte nur noch
nicht ich möchte also keine jenna würde
ich eigentlich am liebsten küste oder
heiraten hier in dem fall weil sie das
einzige mädchen gegen die im bunde ist
aber ich glaube an deshalb will ich
wirklich sagen kann 'die jetta bring ich
um elia für dich heiraten und lassen
will ich küssen anderer stelle will ich
jetzt aber auch das video beenden meine
damen und herren wie hättet ihr die
ganze situation entschieden also hättet
ihr auch zweimal baby getötet oder
hättet ihr gesagt wow ich bin so'n
babynator die will ich auf jeden fall
heiraten und küssen und alles
gleichzeitig reizt uns gern mal in die
kommentare lassen like darf als das ganz
normal machen sollen und jetzt das ziel
vom bio das war's
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wendig und abonnent
sein könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]